ich weiß nicht wie es ihnen zu hause
geht ob sie es heute mitbekommen haben
aber es gab eine stellenausschreibung
und zwar von der hu berlin
was wurde gesucht ein mensch für das amt
antidiskriminierung und es sollte kein
weißer sein gesehen sie gerade
eingeblendet wir bitten daher weiße
menschen von einer bewerbung für diese
beratungsstelle abzusehen ich muss ihnen
sagen es hat mich schockiert was wäre
passiert wenn für eine bewerbung ein
schwarzer ausgeschlossen berg worden
wäre was wäre passiert wenn eine frau
ausgeschlossen worden wäre die
feministinnen in deutschland werden
hochgegangen und das zu recht wie kann
es also sein auch wenn es eine uni ist
das muss man natürlich betonen ist und
studenten aber wie kann es sein dass ein
weißer ausgeschlossen wird ist ein
riesiger für mich ist es rassismus pur
ich bin gespannt wie ist meine runde
sieht
da mache ich den anfang ich würde an
dieser stelle einmal ganz kurz und laut
vorsicht sagen weil ich glaube wir
müssen unterscheiden zum einen wenn ich
das richtig gelesen habe ist es nicht
die humboldt universität die direkt
diese stelle aus geschossen hat also es
ist nicht öffentliche verwaltung staat
es ist eben die studentenschaft und die
sind ja wie wir alle wissen
grundsätzlich tendenziell in linker
positioniert jetzt auch
studierendenschaft würde mich wundern
das ist ja demnächst
für dieses irgendwie die sie in ihrem
alter besser informiert als andere nicht
drin sich dann also weiser alter mann
wundert mich sowas garnicht ja ich bin
das noch alter weißer mann finde ich
übrigens eine frechheit franca und ich
sagen lieber alter weiser mann das
gefällt uns bei der frage wird das wird
bei mir immer mit der sz geschrieben
muss ist aber es überrascht mich dass
wir überrascht sind ich meine das ist
eine ganz normale entwicklung die
letzten jahren was der rassismus
debatten in deutschland geht ich meine
genau solche ideologien werden und
kanzleramt finanziert mit 1 milliarden
euro um rassismus zu bekämpfen aber ihre
vorstellung von rassismus ist so
einseitig ist so rassistisch teilweise
dass man eigentlich nur von minderheiten
spricht und von mehrheiten die die macht
haben die polizei alles instanz wird
nicht nur in frage gestellt sondern als
eine art von gewalt voller
sammeln von männer gesehen alter weißer
mann
postkolonialismus im großen sinne das
sind alle ideologischen vorstellungen
die ihren ursprung leider an der
universitäten haben und leider
mittlerweile unsere medien unsere
debatten bestimmt das stimmt aber es gab
einen grund die haben das auch begründet
warum ein warum weiß ausgeschlossen
wurden von der von der
bewerbung und zwar war nämlich die
begründung dass ein weißer ist nicht
nachfühlen kann also das ist für eine
weiße personen und reisen wer glaube ein
verschuldung also rein psychologisch und
aus der emotionalen ebene heraus
argumentiert würde ich auch sagen nehmen
wir doch ein ganz anderes beispiel mit
wem erzählt man als tochter sage ich
jetzt mal über seine erste liebe seinen
ersten liebeskummer und seine emotion
eigentlich tendenziell der mutter weil
man so zwischen den beiden frauen denn
da ist ein vertrauensverhältnis da
öffnet man sich leichter und wenn ich
jetzt mich diskriminiert fühlen als
farbige person ist ja die frage ob ich
mich davon der weißen person richtig
beraten fühlen also da ist so eine finde
ich so eine psychologische emotionale
ebene die es nicht nicht ganz
glaube ich dass wir einen universitäten
und wer an der uni von innen gesehen hat
weiß dass das der asta in der regel
links ist oder die studentin den
sternchen sternchen sternchen schafft
natürlich auch ganz klar dass es an der
humboldt-uni auch der fall ich glaube
der punkt ob man das nachvollziehen kann
oder nicht ich weiß nicht ob der so
richtig zutrifft es gibt ja auch den
fallas hannover beispielsweise von dem
afrika historiker professor blei 60
jahre geforscht und da wurde jetzt gab
es sollte es im märz in hannover von der
stadt hannover eine diskussionsrunde
geben ein panel vierfaches panel online
natürlich weil die pandemie noch war und
dann gab es eine so genannte anti
diskriminierungs gruppe und die hat
dafür gesorgt dass am ende dieser
professor blei mit seinen 60 jahren
forschungsergebnissen die ja eigentlich
hat natürlich ein weißer alter mann aber
über afrika dass der ausgeladen wurden
kanäle heißt sein also die stadt
hannover lädt ihn ein da gibt es eine
kleine gruppe die sagt nee nee nee du
bist ja weiß du darfst über schwarze
nicht reden und deswegen ist egal was du
bisher geforscht hast spielt alles keine
rolle du hast die falsche hautfarbe
auch das ist rassismus man also dieses
klima gar nicht praktiziert die die
definition von rassismus ist eigentlich
die kategorisieren und homogenisierung
und abwertung von menschen aufgrund von
ihrer hautfarbe und nicht an das ist das
was hier geschrieben werden wenn man
schreibt eine empathie voller jemanden
holen kann jemand der in der lage die
gefühle von anderen wahrzunehmen platz
zu geben dann bin ich einverstanden
aber das nur auf der hautfarbe zu
reduzieren ist nichts anders als ein
reiner klassischer rassismus er man kann
sich vorstellen was aus den studierenden
studenten darf man ja auch nicht mehr
ich auch was zwischen zwei mal sagen
diesen studierenden wenn sie meinen
beruf haben in zehn jahren geworden ist
und was die dann veranstalten in ihrem
einflussbereich in irgendeiner firma wo
sie aber in einer behörde in irgendeinem
büro einer anwaltskanzlei oder was auch
immer das greift ja um sich greift immer
weiter um sich
es gibt ja inzwischen auch rassismus
debatten wenn in einer fernsehsendung
überwiegend oder nur weiß herumlaufen
also da wird ja da müssen unbedingt auch
farbiger das schwarze meer ein um das zu
mischen selbst wenn das bayern spielt
muss ist das ein paar notwendig sonst
ist es eine runde wahrscheinlich auch zu
viele männer
genetisch gesehen 99 prozent aus nahen
osten das als 99 prozent also rund ist
okay eigentlich weil
die gesellschaft wir sind die werden
kann sehr gut also wir sind heute sehr
sehr gut aber ich weiß ja nicht wie es
dir geht frank habe ich hab' ich wurde
auch schon mal also ich wurde auch schon
öfter gebeten zu kommen weil er ja noch
eine frau dabei sein müsste ist es die
auch schon mal passiert die quotenfrau
zu sein muss ich nachdenken also die
quotenfrau so wie du es jetzt beschreibt
es war in der tat noch nicht aber ich
stimme zu dieses diesen ich sag mal
diese empfindlichkeit die teile ich auch
nicht ich die anderen nicht aber nicht
weil ich es respektlos bin sondern weil
ich denke man kann auch sagen die
lehrerin und der lehrer ich finde diese
diese verstärker jungen und erhitzt das
brauchst für mich nicht und ich bin und
da kenne ich mich auch zu einer absolut
alter männer fan weil ich habe einfach
ein podcast mit heiner bremer und der
ist mein politischer mentor und ich zu
seiner erfahrung und die arbeit hier
auch machen möchte diese menschen gar
nicht wissen ja sie hat mich zum stern
geholt das ist natürlich ein jahrzehnt
her daher kann man echt nur so sagen das
sind für mich eher menschen die ich
total schätze auch ob das ein stefan
aust ist davon gibt es viele und ich
finde aber auch mit seinem umfeld und
ein gutes verhältnis zu seinem großen
seinen eltern hat also die für mich gibt
es diese debatte nicht und ich muss auch
sagen ich versuche sie im alltag auch zu
umgehen mich da nicht rein zwar daraus
lernen muss ist glaube ich dass man
solchen debatten hier entgegen tritt
sobald man das feststellen man darf
nicht an sich vorbei ziehen lassen man
muss gleichsam was macht ihr hier
überhaupt gehen auch mal darüber
nachgedacht weil es sonst dass das ufer
derartig aus und du erkennst am ende die
gesellschaft nicht mehr soll nicht
klingen dass man den kampf gegen
rassismus irgendwie lächerlich machen
will darum geht es nicht das ist enorm
wichtig auch cello dann um die frauen
mehr möglichkeiten und
gleichberechtigung anzubieten ist
wichtig aber ich bin ja arabisch
sozialisiert die arabische sprache ist
gender zeit mehr als 2000 jahren und
trotzdem geht die frauen in dieser
gesellschaft nicht gut also man muss
realistische maßnahmen finden die die
gleichberechtigung und
antidiskriminierung
bekämpfung besser und produktiv bekämpft
und nicht auf symbolisieren eigentlich
auch nur trends ja der überdrehten wir
hier erleben dass es rassismus aus
gründen des antirassismus